voici l'animal préféré du roi louis xiv
la poule sultane un animal domestique
présent au château de versailles une des
nombreuses curiosités à découvrir durant
l'exposition les animaux du roi du 12
octobre au 13 février 2022
toute la faune présente au coeur de la
cité royale sur différentes générations
de louis xiv louis saez en passant par
louis 15 on sent qu'il s'est passé
quelque chose d'assez important dans la
conception des animaux de leur personne
le respect l'attachement aux animaux
véritable arche de noé version ancien
régime cette exposition propose 300
oeuvres une rencontre avec les animaux
qui ont participé à la vie du château de
versailles à commencer par cette
éléphante naturalisés de louie 15 une
réalité de l'époque à la ménagerie
royale construite entre 1662 et 1664
aujourd'hui détruite l'idée de du roi
c'était d'avoir une ménagerie qui
montrerait toutes les espèces les plus
curieuses de la terre on avait
évidemment les animaux les plus
extravagants ours enfin tout ce qu'on
pouvait réunir dans la ménagerie était
présent et il ya eu des scènes fameuse
de dissection d'études de ces animaux
puisque le l'esprit était très
scientifique pendant tout l'ancien
régime
le lien avec l'animal c'est aussi lors
d'une activité traditionnelle du roi la
chasse à courre
[Musique]
la façon de gérer les mails émeutes et
les chiens de chasse que ce soit de la
chasse à tir où la chasse à courre est
par exemple le fait de donner des noms à
tous les chiens de chasse qui est une
nouveauté sous louis 15 en fait on ne
les voit pas comme de simples outils qui
servent à poursuivre le gibier ce sont
des compagnons en fait d'un exercice de
ce loisir royal à plumes ou à poils les
animaux sont aussi des symboles
politiques
un moyen pour le roi de représenter son
pouvoir absolu
[Musique]